[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the sun
pippa crira and harry cole welcome to
both of you with us i know right through
until just before midnight so as ever
let's take a look at the front pages
omicron cases in the uk double every
three days the time says as they quote
experts who say it'll be the dominant
strain in the uk within weeks the delhi
telegraph says the booster rollout is at
a standstill and write about a blame
game in whitefall over the speed of the
rollout
the yorkshire post has a story on the
government's crackdown on illegal drugs
writing that thousands of children are
exploited by criminal organizations
the guardian speaks to a former diplomat
who insists that uk government
bureaucracy left afghans to die when
they couldn't escape during the fall of
kabul
the financial times understands the u.s
securities and exchange commission is
scrutinizing an entertainment company
which is part of donald trump's business
empire for alleged financial
irregularities
the metros the metro even has details of
uh the
danish ryder cup golfer accused of
sexually assaulting a woman on an
airplane
and the sun calls prince harry mr
nonsense after he suggested that people
who are unhappy at work should quit
their job
yeah who walks out
uh pippa clearer and harry cole are here
welcome to both of you we're plenty to
discuss in the world of the omicron
variant making a number of the front
pages pippa including the times who like
uh one scientist we spoke to have spoken
to people suggesting that in the uk it's
doubling every three days and what we
are weeks a month maybe a bit more away
from it being the dominant variant is
that is that the lie of the land now
yeah the suggestion seems to be that the
variant which we already knew was
spreading incredibly quickly
[Music]
has done that in the uk as well
and that the cases are doubling every
three days which would very quickly see
it becoming the dominant strain
initially scientists thought that this
might take place in the next few months
it now looks like it could take place
within a few weeks i think we had um
336 cases of omicron now that identified
the minister is expected to be
substantially more than that um and uh
the obviously the concern is that we
still don't know yet the severity of the
of the variant
on uh on people that's not likely to be
known for sure until uh probably sort of
sometime in the next next 10 days or so
pippa i'm going to stop you there we are
however
apologies you keep breaking up and um
we're we're only getting
many of your words but not all of them
so harry we will redial you i think
probably the best thing um harry so the
so we'll write the way through this
article in the times professor neil
ferguson of imperial college who we know
obviously who sits on the government's
nerve tag advisory group said that a
useful early measure of omicron cases
suggested a doubling time of three days
or less
uh scientists at the uk health security
agency have drawn similar conclusions uh
internal government estimates suggest a
doubling time of between three and five
days and all those sources stressed
they're not confident of the exact
numbers there is now a strong signal
that the variant is more transmissible
than delta which is worrying isn't it um
until we find out what it does to people
that's right so i think a lot of people
who
i've been speaking to in government who
sounded quite chipper at the uh back end
of last week uh hoping that actually all
the signs were that the world health
organization was saying it was milder
actually now sounding a bit downbeat now
there's no sort of suggestion that we're
anywhere near the level of sort of
pressure on the nhs yet that to see
restrictions come into effect over
christmas
but
there's whispers and talk now of quite a
bleak january because even if the
disease is is milder
if it does manage to sort of chip away
at the vaccines and just more people get
it across the board
inevitably down the line there will be
pressure on the health service now it is
early days um
the downing street and the department of
health uh the health secretary everyone
was at pains to say this week look we
just don't know it's just too early to
tell let's have a look at it at the back
end of next week and the government have
promised to come back by the time
parliament breaks up for the christmas
holidays uh a week on thursday with a
clearer update so if there is any
changes uh to those restrictions they
will be announced within a sort of a
sort of buffer period of the festive
break
yes and certainly the whole problem is
that even if cases are generally mild it
translates into a large number of
hospitalizations and severe disease it's
the sort of the old pyramid isn't it
really um the times we looked at the
guardian there but the times is also
quoting the scientists behind the zoe uh
covert tracker app and presumably they
talk about tim spector who said people
should work from home and not go to
christmas parties if they have a sniffle
um
should there be more basic things that
the government could bring in now and
why are they so fixated that we should
all be going to our to our rapidly being
cancelled christmas parties i don't i'm
not sure it is a fixation i think it
might just be a more reflection of
reality in the fact that you know the
nation is incredibly
covered weary because whitney popped up
at one of the press conferences i think
about 10 days ago to say look you know
it's all very well i was telling you to
do something but if if people just
ignore it then it's a very different uh
it's a very different ballgame a lot of
polling now public polling and publicly
available polling is showing that people
are slightly at the end of their tether
with being told what to do and they're
sort of taking it into their own hands
now the government provide free tests to
anyone that wants to do them they say
wear a mask if you think you're going to
be an enclosed space and unless you
really do want to start you know
inflicting major damage to the
hospitality industry by closing places
or coming down harder or reintroducing
social distancing then actually there is
a sort of limit to what the government
can can do
and there doesn't seem to be any
political will as far as i can tell
around the cabinet table for further
restrictions anytime soon until
the evidence shows that the nhs really
isn't unable to cope and at the moment
hospitalizations are remaining low
whether that remains the case
after christmas and into january and
february into long winter um remains to
be seen but as it stands the the
appetite just doesn't seem to be there
yes i suppose people take their lead
from government and if they repeat that
you should continue with going to the
office and having your christmas party
then you you you know that's how you
behave uh but the uh the the times also
uh quotes a report outlining the winter
pressures facing the nhs and said that
already more than thirteen thousand
planned operations have been cancelled
in the past two months so whether you
like it or not covet has an impact is it
not in the operation of the health
service of cool
absolutely and that's always going to be
the the issue is is is what you
prioritize you prioritize keeping
hospitals clear for covered patients or
do you prioritize
the nhs catch-up that we're slightly
slightly hearing less and less of at the
time it's the same with the vaccine
rollout there's massive you know sort of
gp backlogs and there's you know gps if
they're going to have to be signed up to
this great big national british effort
as the pm and the leader of the
opposition have called for it means if
gps are jabbing they're not seeing
people there already was huge delays in
getting uh gp appointments back to
normal so
all of this is a trade-off covert has
always been a trade-off i think now the
it before you know the last 18 months
the trade-off has been you know protect
the nhs stay at home
at the exactly sort of cost of the
economy whereas now i think the
trade-offs are going to be a little bit
more stark and actually people are going
to be presented a bit more of a stark
option in the fact that rishi sunak the
chancellor for example isn't prepared to
turn on fellow schemes and underwrite
businesses again unless he absolutely
has to and i think the the debate about
what the nhs is for and what gps are for
will come to the fore in the um in the
new year yeah um pippa i know you've
missed most of that just uh just a quick
thought on whether or not there should
be measures like working from home in
the run-up to christmas uh because the
christmas holidays in itself are a kind
of circuit breaker even though you are
mixing inter-generationally with people
aren't they so in a sense there might be
a you know a pause um for good news at
the end of that effectively
well i certainly think that's what
ministers are hoping but if i'd
apologize if harry has already mentioned
this but scientists like professor tim
spector who is behind the zoe covid
tracker was saying today that he thinks
it's really important that they're
best working from home um over christmas
for everybody because there will still
be some people that that go in to
offices for office workers i should say
that is um because that like you say
will be a natural circuit break and it's
really important to try and delay um the
spread until such a point that
scientists know for sure um how they can
best how they can best tackle the
omicron variant um we're obviously not
there yet um so you know what we don't
want isn't to leave this too late
um harry let's move on to your story
we've only got a minute left uh until
the break um which is uh the double page
spread in the sun
uh on the very tragic case which leads
to that headline arthur's law um tell us
tell us a bit about this then
well as the prime minister
speaks to us tomorrow about the closing
a loophole is part of the governments of
crime week uh so to speak there's a
sentencing bill going through the
commons now there's a loophole that's
going to be closed in this uh in this
bill which would make premeditated
killing of a child um an automatically
all life sentence now the prime minister
is the first to acknowledge tomorrow
that this will have little bearing on
the tragic case of arthur but you know
there was a mps and ministers lining up
today in the house of commons the first
time the commons have really had a
chance to talk about this tragic case to
say look whatever failures there were
the law needs tightening and life should
mean life and um i don't think there'll
be um i don't know many people who
oppose that and um it sort of strikes me
as one of those sort of anomalies that
you have to wonder why that wasn't law
before
both of you stayed there lots more from
both oh pippa you wanted to say
something but do you mind if you just
hold your thought go then very quickly
just that it's not just about tech it's
not just about the sentencing obviously
it's also about the wider systemic
issues that um exist within the within
the social care system social work
system and then feelings that existed
there underfunded
major reform needed
to prevent to make sure that more cases
like this don't happen again
pippa thank you very much indeed harry
as well see you in just a moment lots
more still to come including did uk
bureaucracy leave afghans to die during
and after the fall of kabul we will
discuss that
[Music]
next let's return now to pippa from the
mirror and harry cole from the sun uh
welcome to both of you again uh and
certainly this makes the top of the
times this concern uh that western
leaders have about russia's ambitions in
ukraine
and uh clearly from that meeting tonight
uh pippa there is very little trust
yes that's right well it's not
surprising really um is it's some time
it's what is it five or six years since
russia last launched a bid um an
invasion um of the ukraine and um that
ended in a base of fragile peace process
and which is clearly broken down now and
you've heard ukrainian politicians in
recent days talking about their mass
troops 100 000 troops including tanks
and other military vehicles on their
border clearly very concerned that
another invasion is imminent
it's uh there's this meeting tonight of
um the nato uh nato v2
oh you know honestly it's like being in
my house this is what my house is like
all the time
i think it's your christmas tree lights
that are affecting it i know you've been
uh you've been i know it's not your
fault harry's been typing up this story
anyway uh you know during during the
break trying to file it quickly you've
got 30 seconds to give us your headline
for tomorrow's paper harry
uh i'm not quite sure what the headline
is i can't see that on the computer
but certainly
fears are soaring and interesting that
biden is leading the way biden initiated
this call um he's got the you know he's
trying to convince the europeans of of
russian sort of u.s intelligence that
shows they say that this is actually
very imminent some european leaders a
little bit more skeptical about whether
this is just a bluff
we've run out of time apologies
i'll see you soon thank